So let's compare what we can get from
a multicore versus single core processor
in a new technology.
Suppose that in the previous
technology generation,
we got a processor that has an area
of two centimeters squared.
It was achieving 2.5
instructions per cycle.
And it consumed 100 W,
at 2 GHz frequency.
And this is the highest power that
we can allow this processor to have.
And this 100 W is what
we can reasonably call.
Now let's say we get the new technology
where this same exact processor
would be half the area because
our transistors have shrunk.
Because it's the same design,
it's going to have the same IPC.
And because transistors have shrunk,
we also reduce the power
of this processor when operating at
the same 2 GHz frequency as before.
Now of course because this processor is
smaller in the new technology than in
the old one.
If we want to do the best we can with 2
centimeter square, we have two options.
Our first option is a better
single core processor.
This processor will be designed to
occupy the entire area that we have,
which is 2 cm square.
It's a more complicated processor that
allows us to achieve an IPC of 3.5.
So it executes 3.5 instructions per
cycle, not 2.5 as the old processor.
But because it's a fancier processor and
has more transistors,
it spends 75 W when operating at 2 GHz.
So, the question for you is first, if we
allow this processor to spend all 100
W that we can call,
what is the frequency it can get in GHz?
And if we do that, what is
the speedup this better single core
achieves versus what we can
get in the old technology?
The second option we had
in this new technology
Is to simply put two cores on this chip.
So it's going to be two cores like this.
This is going to get us 2 cm squared.
IPC is going to be 2.5 on each core.
And each core is going to
consume 50 W at 2 GHz.
So we get our entire budget spent by
having these cores operate at 2 GHz.
So the question for you here,
is what's the speedup of this two-core
approach versus the old technology,
assuming, of course, that the old work
can simply be divided among the cores.
So pretty much having two cores
allows us just to split the same work
that we had before onto two cores
without adding any new instructions.
And without sacrificing the IPC.